der zoe 3200 phaeton ist schon seit 30
jahren bekannt doch trotzdem stellt der
astronomie teams noch immer vor riesige
rätsel denn er benimmt sich ganz und gar
nicht wie ein gewöhnlicher astrid nicht
nur seine umlaufbahn ist mehr als
außergewöhnlich und jetzt kommt uns 3200
phaeton mitte dezember tatsächlich sehr
nahe
ob diese riesige gesteinsbrocken
überhaupt wirklich ein asteroid ist was
er mit dem sternschnuppen regen mit der
dezember zu tun hat und wie die nasa die
großen rätsel um 3200 phaeton lösen will
jetzt den blick zum science fiction
herzlich willkommen
sein steckbrief klingt erst einmal alles
andere als besonders außergewöhnlich
3000 seiner väter und hat einen
durchmesser von etwa fünf kilometern
seine form ist kugelförmig alle 3,6
stunden rotierte einmal um seine eigene
achse
er gehört mit zu den erdnahen asteroiden
die potenziell eine gefahr für die erde
darstellen könnten unter ihnen ist 3200
phaeton der drittgrößte am 16 dezember
2017 ist es dann soweit der street wird
mit einem abstand von nur 0,06 9
astronomischen einheiten an der erde
vorbeifliegen
das entspricht etwa einem abstand von
zehn millionen kilometern also wirklich
nah ist dass nicht jemand zum vergleich
unser mond ist 27 mal weiter von uns
entfernt doch mit großen radioteleskopen
ist 3200 phaeton dann von der erde aus
wirklich gut zu beobachten
mit hilfe von radar wellen wie die nasa
aufnahmen von den mysteriöse nass zu
ihnen machen damit soll dann ein sehr
genaues 3d modell erstellt werden denn
es sind gleich mehrere rätsel vdi und
3200 phaeton stellt und das obwohl er
uns schon so lange bekannt ist fangen
wir an mit seiner merkwürdigen
umlaufbahn die ist ellison für mich und
das ist für den großteil der asteroiden
äußerst außergewöhnlich normalerweise
kreisen sie ja auf einer kreisrunden
bahn
anders dagegen 3200 phaeton damit ihr es
euch besser vorstellen könnt seien per e
mail
also seinen sonnennächsten punkt liegt
alle 14 jahre extrem dicht an der sonne
nämlich doppelt so nah wie der merkur
der innerste planet genauer gesagt die
3200 phaeton dann rund 20 millionen
kilometer also 0,4 10 astronomische
einheiten von der sonne entfernt
deswegen auch sein name phaeton der sohn
des sonnengottes helios sein
sonnenfenster punkt dagegen liegt sogar
außerhalb der mars umlaufbahn der ja
unser äußerer nachbar ist kurz noch
einen kleinen fun fact zu seinen namen
der ihn als den sohn des sonnengottes
helios bezeichnet in der griechischen
mythologie vernichtet vätern die erde
fast denn er setzt sie in feuer schon
ein bisschen unheimlich aber ich kann
euch beruhigen
das wird mit dem dezember nicht
passieren wenn man die umlaufbahn von
3200 phaeton betrachtet fällt auf dass
sie also eher kometen
ist sie passt zudem sehr genau zu der
umlaufbahn des meteorstrom der geminiden
sternschnuppen deswegen gibt es die
vermutung dass es sich bei dem
asteroiden um ihre mutter körper handelt
doch das ist das zweite große rätsel um
3200 phaeton denn wie ihr vielleicht
wisst bringen asteroiden normalerweise
keine sternschnuppen hervor stattdessen
werden dafür kometen verantwortlich
gemacht lockerer von eis verpacker staub
löst sich bei jeder runde um die sonne
und das bildet dann den strahlenden
schweif und die sternschnuppen die bei
uns in der atmosphäre verglühten das ist
die drag spur also der schweiz der im
weltraum zurück bleibt und uns mit den
sternschnuppen wünsche beschert handelt
es sich bei 3200 phaeton also eher um
einen kometen manche forschungsteams
vermuten tatsächlich dass es sich um
einen ausgebrannten kometenkern handel
demnach wäre der meteorstrom der
geminiden aus alten zeiten des
ehemaligen kometen von damals also also
noch aktiv war
apropos aktiv es gibt tatsächlich
beobachtungen nach dem 3200 phaeton ab
und an aktiv ist bei den gelegentlichen
ausbrüchen des asteroiden werden hin und
wieder kleine partikel frei doch fest
steht auch er besteht aus einer festen
und steinernen oberfläche ganz so wie
man es von typischen us ihnen kennt und
das wissen wir alle
das ist ganz und gar ein wirklich
ungeeignetes material für sternschnuppen
das rätsel um 3000 tonnen fett ist
tatsächlich groß es gibt das solo mit
teams die seine extreme nähe zur sonne
als problem ansehen demnach beeinflusst
die gigantische gravitation der sonne
3200 phaeton so sehr dass er langsam
zerschreddert wird fest steht jedenfalls
mitte dezember wird uns der mysteriöse
gesteinsbrocken dann ganz nah sein und
alle die ein teleskop haben werden ihnen
vielleicht sogar selbst sehen können
links vom sternbild pegasus und zwar in
der ersten nachthälfte in den nächten
vorher gibt es auf jeden fall die
geminiden also den sternschnuppen regen
am himmel zu sehen und vielleicht wissen
wir mitte dezember mehr wenn die nasa
dann die großen rätsel um 3200 phaeton
vielleicht lösen kann wenn ihr kein
video dazu und auch zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann durch media
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
auf die glocke nur dann verpasst er kein
video her also hier geht es weiter mit
dafür draufklicken hast du jeden
bedrohen die erde jederzeit ansonsten
bis dann bleibt hat